hi my name is aekta sarangi and I did my
BTech in computer science then I started
my career as a Java developer after that
I moved to British Telecom as a project
manager I saw data science as an
upcoming field and I wanted to give it a
try being myself a techie person and I
always wanted to do freelancing as well
and that's when I decided to quit bTW
after serving it for two years I started
looking out for data science courses
which are available online or the live
classroom trainings so there were a lot
of platforms and it was very confusing
which one to choose for no based upon my
needs and requirements so that's how
after doing lot of research I came
across simply learned I knew simply
learned through my friends who have
already done the courses through that so
I got a chance to look at the various
courses which are available with simply
learning data science
so then I exploded various courses which
are available and simply learned so they
were courses which were data science
with our data science with SAS and I was
really not very sure that which goes to
go for so I was thinking that I'll go
for one course at a time starting with
data science with our then SAS and then
Python but when I spoke to one of the
reps from simpler they guided me that
they have something called a master
course in data science which will
actually give me an opportunity to learn
all the available languages which are
present and it will give me an overall
holistic picture of the entire data
science platform along with that this
course was very cost effective so after
having a conversation with them then I
made up my mind and I decided to enroll
myself in the Masters data science
program of simply learning once I took
this master's course I saw that the
course was very interesting there were
live classroom trainings so the live
classroom trainings which were there
really helped us to connect with the
instructor and also helped resolve all
our queries in during the class I also
did data science with Python and big
data and Apache kafka programs which
were part of the master data science
program so it really helped me to learn
you know starting from the scratch and
then going go into the advanced topics I
didn't got an opportunity with the
us-based startup called Auditor it's a
tech startup
focusing for women and it provides a
great flexible work platform so it
caters to take women who are based out
in Middle East or southeast asia and who
are looking for freelancing
opportunities i'm working with them from
past 9 to 10 months and I have worked on
varied kind of projects like web
scraping projects data science projects
including machine learning and then data
analytics projects which had tableau
power bi so all the technologies which I
learned in my simple data science
program I'm able to use them in my
current job which I'm doing in auditor
and then I'm also working with pact
which is a uk-based publication and
preparing a lot of video courses for
them I have prepared courses like ups
mastering and sells Python in future I
aspire to be a subject matter expert in
the data science field where I developed
my niche in scripting and data
visualization like tableau and power bi
outside my work I really like to travel
to different places and explore the
world so recently I have been to places
like butta and obey and Japan and that I
was able to do because I was doing
freelancing
so I really like this kind of freedom
and that's why I ventured into the
freelancing field
[Music]